have you ever done joe rogan no yeah i
mean either no i needed him dude i just
feel like
i needed him i just hold up i was in a
meeting with lauren michaels
and i was like i'm definitely gonna get
fired and that's fine i'll just do i'll
do rogan next week yeah it'd be bigger
yeah yeah and then it never happened i
was just sitting there looking at myself
you're like oh dude
rogan come on come on it's so well at
least dude at least you not only a dish
for snl but got
snl i feel like especially doing comedy
in new york
nowadays or like being a comedian to be
like legitimized i always felt like
either you have to like audition for snl
or get snl or recently like do the joe
rogan podcast and i never got
either one i never been on rogan i never
even auditioned for snl like i never
even you've been great
i never even got a chance like everybody
like not even nothing like
not sent to tape not got er i feel like
at least everybody auditions for it and
they just get told no ionized
and you even don't even know like i was
saying that the honest ones being like
you know we've never auditioned you know
it's like no i auditioned for snl like
what are you [ __ ] like
oh audition what do you stink yeah he
auditioned for snl like he was like dude
i did for snl like this first three
years of comedy like what do you suck
i was just like [ __ ] so but dude i mean
wow that's wild
never i never i never auditioned i never
i got it [ __ ] did wrong after being
in new york
yeah you're the best guy we've ever seen
yeah just immediately
just immediately i never got those
chances but what can you do i mean you
know
i don't even want it anymore let me
graveyard
i just come on the very first time like
i'm on stage like live i just beat the
[ __ ] out of pete
you start [ __ ] you're trying to make
me look [ __ ] stupid
for no reason
[ __ ] put chain a headlock i'm like
literally he's like losing his breath in
consciousness
when it's live and then i kick the back
of the set down and i go [ __ ] drop 20
20.
i thought about it i thought dude that
would have been great thought about a
couple of those
so they were like we got to try you know
they were trying to get me just
to get to the first show right because
it was so close to the first show
like if we could just get you on the
first show people will see that you're
not a nazi
and i was like it would be funny to go
out and just spaz oh we're live
dude but it's it's one of those things
where giannis and i you know use you an
example
um and even like you know schultz where
it's like
you like the power of the internet and
the power of the fans is like
you know your patreon what is
patreon.com so it's like huge patreon
because like all that stuff like when a
normal people
see this cancel culture [ __ ] it's
like
no like it makes it almost makes our
careers
smaller and bigger at the same time it's
like for a smaller niche audience we get
a lot bigger which is what you want
anyway because it's like
you could sell way more tickets than
anyone on that show and it's like even
i was actually thinking about you this
weekend and it was crazy i was like
oh we needed a feeling i was like oh
let's get shane because when i was in
salem massachusetts and we did this uh
tour about the salem witch trials and
the hysteria and the salem witch trials
it's not the same thing
but like it happened in 1692 but i was
wondering like in 1687
was it a little bit like this like you
get you know they'll be like oh you're a
[ __ ] you because you're a witch for
looking at a cow wrong you're a witch
and then you're like well
i'm not aware and then people are like
he's not a witch but then as time goes
on
gets a little slow and then fine boom
we're hanging people from trees
hanging the witches from trees and then
it's like i wonder if like now it's like
because now it's getting to the point
where like
you say anything like bill burr was
trying to get cancelled because of a
joke on a monologue it's it felt it
feels a little salem witchy
kind of it's a little puritanical is
coming back puritanical
yeah for sure definitely puritanical but
you know yeah i also
in this analogy was doing witchcraft
yeah so they kind of got me right they
were like that's a witch i was like
i'm not a witch you're like i've got a
witcher on a broom just [ __ ]
warts all over your face i got a mop
yeah warts on my dick i um
i think i think uh yeah dude i've
definitely you know i heard an
interesting thing about the witch trials
what yeah thomas i'm joe rogan
tell me oh wow you're not gonna have us
on and he's doing my [ __ ] podcast
did you like billboard's monologue
though in snl i did i loved it yeah i
saw him uh
yeah i said i heard it before yeah
i was doing a show and he did it it was
great and uh yeah it was great it was
it's almost to the point now where i
kind of feel like on twitter
i think that either either
snl pays for the hate like they pay
people to have hate tweets so people
like look at their show more
or like the russian bots are have
infiltrated social media
so much because there's really nobody
my mother you can't get more catholic
and religious
and kind of uh proper and she's you know
offended by everything than my mother
she's not offended by everything but
she's very like oh please don't use that
language like that and she loved bill
burr's monologue she was like i
and she's the first one to be like i
don't like donald trump i don't
you know i she's very like uh you know
um
uh she like minds her p's and q's and
she was like i loved i loved it i think
she was like i understand the gay joke
the gay uh gay pride month joke and the
black history
month joke could have been a little bit
but she was like but why
why do comedians exist don't they exist
to kind of touch the line and i was like
yeah
that's what i thought yeah these [ __ ]
bots came out
yeah no i heard i heard him do that in
front of a
it was funny to watch people not like it
right like
yeah yeah and he did at the stand there
was a bunch of
just chicks that were not off they've
never been [ __ ] enslaved
that's actually dude i was like that's a
lot yeah you're like whoa
you know but you know what you know what
the only thing i will say which i think
is is
somewhat positive is i understand uh you
know people can hate on
this or that the fact that snl allowed
that monologue i think is progress
for comedians and i think that was their
way of saying hey we actually do
we are supporting comedy a little bit
more now
because like it's not like he just
[ __ ] improv that
that set had to be approved and it was
yeah they they still i think there's
still a cl
there's still some people there that are
like like kate mckinnon non-stop with
like
the [ __ ] ruth bader ginsburg thing
yeah just
yeah so i think there's like a cloud of
like seniority there that's like
very very progressive right to the point
where it's
kind of suffocating the show right so
right no i know
i don't know it's just we'll talk about
comanches
the only reason why i've started to talk
i just want to talk about burr's
monologue because i loved it but
but it did rule i agree i was happy to
see it i heard him
when again when i saw the stand when he
brought up canceled culture i was like
yes yes i say it say
it help nah dude no but here on this
podcast you know we love everybody
and um you know that's the thing it's
like you could just say that and just be
like that
i'm telling you dude having a puerto
rican daughter is just the best it's
like
if some progressive white chick is like
you're racist i'm like am i
i'm making minorities what are you doing
you dumb [ __ ]
i like it sorry yeah yeah really i'm
adding to the [ __ ] minority
population
what uh thomas jefferson said yeah yeah
that's how much i love them they're like
you have slaves he's like
i'm making more i'm making more exactly
i'm making i'm making my argument
no dude that's how much i love them so
i'm creating them
that's what i like the spanish [ __ ]